Matthew what drew you to this project
how did you become involved with Mexican
cartels and vigilante groups so I first
I first heard about the story through
some articles that I read I started
filming in Arizona I was there for about
four or five months and then my father
actually sent me an article about the
autodefense s in Michoacan and right
when I read it I knew I wanted to create
this parallel story of vigilantism on
both sides of the border so you started
with the Arizona people how did you get
involved with the group why did they
learn to trust you
you know I think it's actually much
harder to get access to the Arizona
vigilantes took me about four or five
months through a lot of phone calls and
sort of pre-production to gain their
trust and and then eventually once I
stepped foot down they're sort of you
know whereas in Mexico I reached out to
the doctor
I got a read about him in article I read
a Wall Street Journal article and and
then reached out through the journalist
and I got on the phone with him the next
day and he said I told him I want to
come down I want to document your story
oh and I commend the story of the outer
defenses and two weeks later I was down
there filming so tell us about your
first impressions of him he certainly
seemed to be someone who loved the
camera you know he's a complex guy and I
think you know one of my goals with this
film was the sort of exam and what
pushes what drives men and women to take
up arms to take the law into their own
hands you know I constantly have sort of
wondered well you know what would I do
if I was in that situation what would I
do if my sister was raped my brother was
was hanging from a bridge you know would
I take up arms but I fight violence with
violence is that right that just is
vigilantism sustainable and then I think
clearly as we see how the film plays out
we end up with a much different story
than I ever could have imagined so as
you were shooting this you watched your
own
compass begin to change as ever enacted
for vigilantism to be enough but IIIi
you don't want to examine what provoked
other people do I mean I wasn't about to
join their better defenses but you know
it's also hard to judge unless you're in
that situation so I really wanted to go
down you know they've been a lot of
stories about narco violence about you
know the drug wars and I really you know
I didn't want to make a policy film I
don't want to make a film with Talking
Heads I want to make an experiential
film in which I put myself and my crew
right in the middle of the action and
when I first started especially in
Mexico I thought it was a very simple
hero villain story of guys in white
shirts fighting against guys and black
shirts and over time that story changed
and the lines between good and evil
became much more blurry let's talk about
time how long were you actually down
there embedded with them I was down
there for about in Mexico for about nine
months one to two weeks of every month
and I actually think that's what allowed
me to get into the sort of dark corners
that I was able to get into you know
there's there other people down there
covering the story you know but they
often will go down for one day two days
three days four days it's so difficult
to tell its story to tell a new story in
that amount of time and you know I had
the fortune to be able to be there for
so long to develop relationships to
develop storylines you know over a
nine-month period did you see those
storylines begin to change in ways that
you had never anticipated completely I
mean I I really ended up with a much
much different story than I then I
started with and I'm not a war reporter
I've never been in situations like this
before and obviously you know as you saw
in the film I found myself and you know
meth labs shootouts torture chambers
places that you know were frightening
and I and I never sort of could dream
that I'd be in those situations but you
know that's where the story led me can
you take us into what it was like as a
filmmaker to ink
after these kind of dangerous situations
were you ever fearful for your life I
think I'd be crazy or inhuman if I
didn't fear of my life there's many many
you know fighting moments that first
shootout you know was particularly
frightening frightening you know every
single day we wore bulletproof vests but
that particular day was it was really
really hot and nothing was going on we
were at a car store one of the other
defensive commanders was gonna buy a car
and so it seemed like nothing was going
on where based I don't like a you know
lunch break
grab my lunch and then BOOM something to
get this call that Janecka and caballo
those two assassins were in a warehouse
we jump in the car and then you know
suddenly were in the middle of a
shootout and that was the first time
that I ever was in a situation like that
before and actually think that the craft
of filmmaking being behind the camera
focusing on on focusing on exposure on
framing you know making sure the record
button was on so helped calm me down in
those situations but but I think I will
say though that despite you know the
adrenaline moments the scariest moment
for me by far was an interview that I
did with the woman Milagros whose
husband was kidnapped by the cartel and
was chopped up to pieces in front of her
and and then burned to death and to be
in this room with this woman and to look
there and to sort of see these deeply
hollow eyes almost as if her soul had
been sucked out of her to hear describe
these horrors and to think that were the
same species of human beings that would
do that to other people that sort of
mentally stuck with me much more so than
any of those other moments as the film
progresses in Mexico of course we
discover the government's involvement
and the kind of fluid boundaries between
the cartel and the government was this
something from reading that you knew was
down the line the line in a sense
you know I think part of what the story
is is is what happens when government
institutions fail what happens when
people live in a society where they have
no one to turn to and a lawless society
I mean that young woman in the beginning
of the film in this scene when they kick
out the army and she's screaming at the
at the policeman her whole family was
killed by the cartel her parents I think
her dad was maybe like seven years old
he was on a respirator they kidnapped
him kidnapped his her mom and her two
brothers and and and murdered them and
she couldn't go to the police we were
one of the first people she ever told
and to live in a society where you know
the very institutions that are there to
protect you either aren't there or if
they are there they're in collusion with
the cartel I mean it's a it's a scary
world and that's where this movement was
born out of unfortunately you know the
movement was changed and and co-opted
and evolved in jail or dr. Morales is
still in jail it's almost just a year
since he's been in jail there's been no
due process no trial you know his family
and his supporters believe that he is in
jail to silence him and that until the
government wants to hear from him that
it will remain in jail so at its heart
are these two men he's two very very
complex men they're both 55 years old al
doctor and Naylor they both believe that
the government has failed them they both
taken the law in their own hands to to
fight for what they believe in but the
circumstances are quite different
you know Mexico the suffering is you
know amazing unbearable 80,000 plus
people killed since 2007 20,000 plus
people disappeared since 2007 whereas in
Arizona obviously that violence is not
happening
it'sit's silly more theoretical to fear
that the Mexican drug wars will seep its
way across their border so you know
obviously they're they're quite
different the stories
you know held together by a sort of
distrust of the you know institutions to
protect us and a desire to bring take
the law into their own hands